je suis né à gauche et je vais mourir à
gauche
quand tu as de l'argent tu as plus de
couleurs donc tout et je dire je
rentrais pas en boîte de nuit et dans
une boule un jour je suis rentré parce
qu'on m'a reconnu j'étais noir j'étais
plus noir que j'ai croisé soit dans le
vestiaire on dans un vestiaire
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont tenu des
propos racistes à moi quoi en me disant
je me souviens un gars qui un jour
m'avait dit j'avais dit je vais
peut-être aller à marseille m'avait dit
mais l'armée va pas à marseille et
beaucoup de noirs et beaucoup de la ram
et je m'étais dit mais de trop comme à
qui tu parles
ça me fait délirer et pour moi dans ce
dans toute ma vie les blaireaux c'était
ce type là quoique avait rien capté que
nous nous les footballeurs qui venons
d'un quartier on évolue on est on est
capable de de gravité dans plein
d'endroits on change de milieu social
ont de l'argent et en même temps on
vient d'un quartier on est on a beaucoup
là cette double culture aussi moi je
viens de l'île maurice mes parents mes
arrière grands parents de l'inde
ça c'était une force quoi que d'autres
n'avaient pas
je peux pas moi être heureux dans mon
coin tout seul ça marche pas il faut que
je participe à la société moi j'ai
bénéficié du système français jeunes
d'assurance chômage la sécurité sociale
les allocations familiales et ça m'a
beaucoup apporté ça m'a permis à un
moment de sortir de mon quartier
donc je veut renvoyer l'ascenseur à tous
ces gens là évidemment que moi quand je
vais à l'hôpital ses gratte c'est gratos
ici pas gratos c'est pas vrai c'est
parce que le système français fait que
c'est gratos parce que nous on paye des
impôts parce que il ya la seule vérité
de tout le monde qu'on paye tous et
c'est ça qui est super dans notre pays
il faut que ça continue
moi je suis pour qu'on paye les impôts
je suis pour payer les sf parce que j'en
ai bénéficié un jour et je suis pour que
d'autres aussi en bénéficier
ça m'empêche pas à moi de vouloir aussi
mon confort d'être bien dans ma vie
c'est pas inconciliables par contre ceux
qui sont très riches je suis sûr que ça
changera leur vie qui soit juste un peu
moins riches
la france se construit comme ça la
transmission quand on donne à nos
enfants et les riches donnent espère
donner tout et pendant ce temps là c'est
plutôt les autres qui font fonctionner
le système sur l'endettement sur la
consommation sur la surconsommation
je me dis qu'un mec qui manifeste un
samedi après-midi il a autre chose à
faire normalement ils préféreraient être
tranquille où avec sa famille ses
enfants à se promener et donc s'il monte
à paris où il monte dans une grande
ville manifester parce qu'ils souffrent
parce qu'il galère parce que c'est
difficile de finir les fins de mois
quand c'est que les finir les fins de
mois j'ai plutôt tendance à avoir envie
de les soutenir
j'ai le sentiment aussi qu' on est
déconnecté de la france paris avec la
transition écologique le progrès
l'intelligence artificielle et puis tu
as des gens en fait non c'est pas ça
leur réalité et nous on est déconnecté
ces gens là ils sont venus nous rappeler
que bah ouais ils vivent pas la même
chose que nous et que c'est dur pour eux
[Musique]
tous ces gens qui sont à la télé pour la
plupart un beau coup les gens qui les
politiques ils viennent pas du même
milieu ne viennent pas d'eux ils ont pas
pour la plupart pavillon hlm ils n'ont
pas vécu à la campagne ils ont pas sont
pas dans les mains dans le cambouis
ils peuvent pas savoir ce que c'est donc
après quand quand ils comprennent pas
que des gens viennent alors dit nous on
n'arrive pas à finir les fins de mois
c'est dur il le vit l'ont pas vécu les
politiques quand il parle aujourd'hui je
ne comprends rien à ce qu'ils disent je
comprends rien ces petits pas de
dommages suis un citoyen normal français
il parle pas à moi et je en même temps
je crois tellement aux politiques
j'y crois toujours je crois que c'est
par eux que ça la solution peut passer
mais en même temps que pour l'instant je
suis souvent déçu il ya je pense des
solutions mais il faut avoir envie de le
faire